merci d'avoir scellé votre temps à
Monsieur le Ministre la parole est à
présent monsieur rené Beaumont pour le
groupe Union pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il est
maintenant il y a maintenant un peu plus
de 2 ans que la France et la
Grande-Bretagne ont signé un partenariat
de défense historique
ce 31e se met franco-britannique a
permis de raviver l'esprit du sommet de
Saint-Malo en 98 et les accords de
Lancaster House furent une formidable
occasion d'impulser une vraie dynamique
en matière de coopération militaire qui
rime avec mutualisation
en période de crise efface ce manque
d'attraction pour la défense de la part
des autres membres les autres pays
membres de l'Union économique
l'Union européenne ce type de
coopération bilatérale constitue un
exemple et même plus un moteur pour
l'avenir de la défense européenne
bien sûr sur le terrain en termes
d'opération extérieure l'Europe et la
l'Europe de la défense se fait de plus
en plus attendre et les exemples libyens
et Maliens se passent de commentaires
pour démontrer l'inertie européenne
mais versez dans le rôle c'est
scepticisme aujourd'hui en matière de
défense est une et d'une telle facilité
politique et intellectuelle que nous
devons nous y refuser
la France et la Grande-Bretagne sont les
deux contributeurs de loin les plus
importants de l'automne après les
États-Unis et assureront d'ici à moins
de 10 ans près de 65 % des dépenses de
défense de l'Union européenne
ces deux nations atomiques qui partagent
la même vision en termes de dissuasion
nucléaire sont encore sont encore les
rares défenses nationales au sein de
l'Union européenne qui demeure
mondialement crédible
aussi monsieur le ministre nous espérons
que le Conseil de défense de vendredi ne
m'a l'air pas ni mes modestes propos ni
encore moins le travail réalisé par nos
deux pays depuis la signature des
accords de Lancaster House ces
engagements sont des références en
matière de coopération structurelle
renforcée
les objectifs des deux traités qui en
découlent grâce à la mutualisation nous
permettent déjà de dégager des économies
annuelles à hauteur de 150 millions par
an
mieux cette coopération militaire
s'accompagne d'une coopération
parlementaire grâce à l'engagement du
président Josselin de Rouen une
véritable collaboration entre notre
commission et nos homologues allemands
c'est instaurer initiative que bien sûr
le président jean-Louis Carrère poursuit
désormais très activement il faut poser
la question je termine tout de suite et
qui fait l'unanimité de notre commission
en ces temps difficiles c'est consensus
devrait inspirer le gouvernement à
poursuivre le dialogue
franco-britannique seul capable
aujourd'hui de créer la véritable
émotion d'Europe de défense mon souci
vous l'avez compris monsieur ministre et
de connaître l'avenir que vous réservez
au fameux traité de Lancaster House
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le sénateur merci de cette
question ça me permet de rejoindre le
point de vue que vous développez et de
dire de vous dire que la coopération
franco-britannique structuré dans le
cadre des accords de Lancaster House se
poursuit de manière positive ça me
permet indirectement de répondre à
Monsieur buffet je sais pas si il est il
est parti mais vous lui direz
que
il faisait l'éloge de Monsieur Cameron
que Monsieur Camon l'année dernière
avait fait baisser le budget de la
Défense britannique de 8%. et je suggère
cela pour sa méditation du week-end mais
donc c'est relativement facile
aujourd'hui de rétablir la situation je
voudrais vous dire aussi que le traité
de Lancaster House sa présente un
avantage une singularité nouvelle
puisqu'il comporte un volet nucléaire
c'est une avancée significative de la
coopération avec le Royaume-Uni mais
au-delà de cela nous progressons de
manière
intelligente et loyal sur l'ensemble du
dispositif qui a été signé par exemple
la force expéditionnaire commune
interarmée là c'est Jef est en cours de
constitution et à atteindra son côté
opérationnel plein en 2016 nous avons
initié en matière opérationnelle des
exercices communes dont un très gros un
exercice très important en présence des
deux ministres de la Défense en octobre
dernier et nous mettons en place des
interopérabilités de système
d'information et de communication et le
partage du renseignement au-delà de cela
nous avons aussi initié une coopération
sous ma responsabilité en matière de
drone à la fois les drones de théâtre
watch keeper mais aussi aussi les drones
de générations futures Lucas en
particulier c'est des signes de
coopération très très actifs je ne parle
pas du drone mal dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure je parle de des autres extrêmes
en petits en très grands des
technologies du futur et nous avons
aussi une collaboration très étroite en
matière de guerre des mines et nous
avons transféré à l'ocar cette
responsabilité est sous une le patronage
d'une équipe franco-britannique dont les
relations sont bonnes elles ne sont pas
exclusives et nous disons au Britannique
que nous avons une relation bonne avec
eux mais que ce ne nous empêche pas
d'avoir des relations avec le groupe de
Weimar ou avec le groupe de vice-grade
puisqu'il y a une réunion commune des
ministre de la défense de ces ensembles
régionaux il y a peu de temps il faut
que ce soit dans la transparence
et qu'on dise à chacun ce que l'on fait
avec l'autre pour éviter les
incompréhensions voir les grincements
qui ont pu se produire dans le passé
vous avez raison de dire que c'est parce
que nous aurons une coopération
capacitaire que nous pourrons aboutir à
une gestion plus économe des de l'argent
public rare en cette période que ce soit
en Grande-Bretagne ou en France Merci en
vous remerciant monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous en avons fini avec
la séance des questions cribles je vais
suspendre la séance